speaking of this issue of life
terrible story coming out of california
a ucla grad student was stabbed to death
at a furniture store
by a relatively young man shawn lavalle
smith he stabbed brianna kupfer
who is only 24 years old stabbed her to
death last thursday afternoon as she
worked at the croft house store
on la brea avenue in los angeles very
familiar with la brea avenue it's a nice
furniture store
she's a ucla grad student in design
she's been
identified as the victim of this career
criminal with a rap sheet that includes
charges of assault with a deadly weapon
carrying a concealed weapon assault on a
police officer possession of a stolen
vehicle and other charges as well
this guy's got a rap sheet a mile long
if politicians had done their job and
locked this criminal up
this young girl would be alive
but because they didn't do their job
because they won't lock criminals up
she is dead
is this compassionate we are told that
letting criminals off the hook for their
crimes and letting them out of prison
when they
do have to face consequences for their
crimes
is compassionate
we are told that america has an
over-incarceration problem specifically
with regard to to black men and so we've
got to let the criminals out of prison
is that compassionate to this woman
who's dead
is that compassionate to her family is
that compassionate to her co-workers
to any other ordinary american worker
who now is worried has to fear for their
lives if they're in a major city with a
big crime problem
is that even compassionate to the guy
the guy just killed this woman
he now i suspect will finally go to
prison
he's done a terrible thing that has
really destroyed his life is that
compassionate no i don't think so had he
been
thrown in the can for any of his other
crimes maybe he would have reformed but
now he he
he's not going to have that opportunity
before he killed someone the dems are
pushing this stuff
but the republicans are going along with
it
donald trump donald trump is one of the
most conservative republicans to come
along in my lifetime and donald trump
pushed the jailbreak bill
donald trump pushed the first step act
to let criminals out of prison it was
one of the
biggest disagreements i ever had with
the trump administration
why are you doing that this issue of
crime
is one of the clearest areas of
divergence between the american people
and both major parties
the american people want criminals
locked up they don't want crime on their
streets
democrats do want crime on the streets
and republicans all too often go along
with it it's crime and immigration those
are the two big issues where the people
the vast majority of the people think
one thing and both major parties think
something completely different
the democrats want to let these
criminals out of prison with one
exception
they want to let everybody out of prison
there's one person they want to put into
prison do you know who that is
donald trump it would be donald trump
i'm glad you like that clip
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe for free to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you